easy but ideals thank you I'd like to
thank the organizers for inviting me to
give this talk this work is with Ronald
Kramer and Leia duka at CWI and Oded reg
F at NYU so take it pretty easy we won't
be too technical on this talk but we're
back to lattices and we saw a lot of
talks and very interesting crypto you
can do based on sis and lwe and the ring
versions of these and ideal lattices and
so forth but these problems haven't
taken over the world entirely there are
other lattice based or lattice related
crypto systems that don't rely directly
on the these oblivion SAS problems and
in particular a few recent crypto
schemes including so smart for
Katherine's simplification of Gentry's
original fhe the breakthrough garg
gentry and halevi multilinear maps
simplification of that Duta langlois
salient steinfeld i think and then this
paper by campbell groves and shepherd
who normally don't publish because
they're part of the GCHQ the uk's NSA
right so all of these papers maybe not
independently but semi independently
proposed crypto systems that share the
this common element of how they generate
keys so to generate a secret key they
will fix some ring so for example our
favorite power of two cyclotomic rings
here Z X mod X to the n plus one for
Anna power of two and the way they
choose the secret key is to just choose
a short generator a short element rather
G in that ring ok so from our Gaussian
distribution or something like that
reasonably short not too short but not
not very long either and then as the
public key they output a bad basis of
the ideal generated by G so this all
multiples of G in the ring you can
compute efficiently a bad basis for
example the Hermit normal form is sort
of the worst possible basis you can give
out of the baddest basis you could give
out for that ideal so the public key
will be this this basis B and a secret
key will be this short element
gia the short generate orgy of the ideal
okay so if you wanted to crypt analyze
or try to break these schemes here's one
way you could do it in two steps the
first step would be to solve what has
been called the principal ideal problem
so that says you know given this integer
basis B of this this ideal I let's first
try to find some generator of the ideal
okay so find some generator H maybe it's
not short okay but it generates exactly
those elements in the ideal so the ideal
I is H times are ok and then anyone want
to guess what step two is let's make the
generator short okay so let's solve the
short generator problem i'm just making
this name up it's not really standard
but this problem is okay given an
arbitrary generator h of a principle
ideal let's recover the short generator
G up to trivial equivalences like well
negative G is just as good right so and
there are other symmetries that that
don't plug don't cause any problems so
this is one way you might go about
attacking the scheme yes yes exactly so
actually thanks Vico I'll pay you later
for the question it's actually not
obvious a priori that that G is even
uniquely defined here I mean there could
be two generators which are short enough
or equally good or maybe there's another
generator that's even shorter than the g
you chose so it turns out that really
any short enough element of the ideal
suffice is to break to break these
schemes so you don't even need to have a
generator necessarily
not necessarily I mean you could break
the you could decrypt using any short
enough vector in the ideal it need not
be a generator right but in fact we will
show or we'll see that in fact G is
uniquely defined which is somewhat
surprising and that there are ways to
recover that G up to these trivial
equivalences so we'll be talking about
these two steps right now and let's just
see what does it cost to do these two
steps so the first part that is given
this basis of the ideal to find some
generator H not necessarily short so
this has been investigated reasonably
reasonably well over the past couple of
decades it's not the most popular
problem ever but there are you know
shows up in books here and there so the
best state-of-the-art right now is that
you can do it in sub exponential time
but to to the end of the two-thirds via
classical algorithm by BS and fekr and
follow up by vs just about a year or two
ago and at the same time there has been
major progress toward a polynomial time
quantum algorithm to solve this so that
follows from work by eisen-steen Trager
at all recently BS song and also the
folks from GCHQ that I mentioned before
so the exact status of whether this is
solved or not is a bit unclear depending
on who you ask they say it's definitely
solved or it might be solved something
like that so I'm not the person to ask
about this but it seems to be very
plausible that there is a poly time
quantum algorithm for for this phase of
the attack was our question
yeah what do I mean by measure progress
I don't know so keep keep an eye on but
I don't think it'll be too long before
this whole thing will be resolved one
way or the other okay so then the second
part of the attack is the short
generator problem so given given this
generator H that you found let's convert
it to a short generator and what we'll
see is that in general you know given
any generator of a ideal to find an
equivalent short generator is
essentially the closest vector problem
on something called the log unit lattice
for the ring and I'll define this and
I'll get pictures of it and demion
actually for foreshadowed a little bit
on this but in fact what has emerged
from the past year a couple years as
people talk about these cryptosystems is
in fact it's actually a potentially
easier problem than arbitrary CVP so you
know you could throw you know noah and
daniel and delicious CVP algorithm at
this but it would be exponential time
but actually what we have is something
called a bounded distance decoding
problem at least in our cryptographic
setting and so i'll give more details on
this but the upshot is that the fact
that there exists an unusually short
generator G for our ideal means that
actually we're in this bounded distance
decoding regime so we don't have an
arbitrary target that we have to decode
on the log unit lattice but rather we
have a point which is say unusually
close to that log unit less and that
turns out to make a huge difference in
this in
so this Campbell groves in Shepherd
paper had a very surprising client
minute that they said oh actually the
short generator problem is easy in power
of two cycle comics and that's pretty
much all they said which was not not so
believable to me I thought about this
question a little bit before and then
their paper came out and there weren't
any details so I didn't change my
opinion after reading the paper but it
turned out they were right so we asked
them and they gave a few more details
and they said yeah we reran experiments
and confirmed that this this works but
there really weren't there was no
explanation of what's what's really
going on and certainly nothing
theoretical to that we could hang our
hat on to understand really what was
quite going on here so that is basically
the goal of and the purpose of this
present work is to actually make this
second the second claim rigorous and to
prove it so what we show is that in this
cryptographic setting that I showed you
where you generate keys in this way the
short generated problem can be solved
classically in polynomial time for any
prime power cyclothymic so we generalize
a bit beyond power of 2 2 prime power
cyclothymic once you're giving a
principal idea so you the the problem is
you are given the you're given H exactly
so you're given H and you want to
recover G and we're in the cryptographic
setting which is shorthand for you know
that G was generated say from a Gaussian
or from as a relatively short element
it's just genesis so your message cheese
you think this group the systems are
broken you should use it right so what
does this mean for a ring base crypto
thanks
pterence yes a part 1 um you know well
let's say what what does it mean right
what the consequences algorithm to find
the classically dictionary yes so even
the security implications right right so
for what does this mean for those
systems and for you know ring base
crypto more generally so the four works
i referenced there they're obviously
weakened classically now we now have a
rigorous sub exponential time attack in
the dimension so if you were hoping to
use you know moderately small dimension
like 256 or something that that's
probably not probably not safe and then
they're quantumly broken modulo the
exact level of how well this quantum
result has been established fighting the
same g yes yes so we'll recover the
secret key you know up to these trivial
equivalences plus/minus and things like
that does it work for larger plps issue
to be perfect polynomial sarah p in
order for these systems to make sense
the dimension has to be polynomial it
has to be pretty small the polynomial
there's no characteristic anywhere in
here this is just we're in the we're in
the emphasis cyclotomic for some m which
is reasonably small in the hundreds or
thousands theorem okay here i knew fun
cause it's tough yes any any prime power
yes so p can be a large prime as long as
P to the K is you know small enough that
you can actually write down ring
elements the theorem holds right
so what does it going back to what it
means obviously those those reference
works are classically weakened or
quantumly broken perhaps that's the bad
news the good news is that the rest of
ring base crypto seems to be unaffected
and the reason is basically the its
security is lower bounded by a harder or
what appear to be harder certainly more
general problems so here is kind of an
artificial landscape of the kinds of
problems that you might consider using
or being useful in crypto so on the Left
we have what are these acronyms the
shortest vector problem on principle
ideals that are guaranteed to have a
very short generator unusually short
generator okay so this is the problem
that that has now been attacked so this
is a this one you want to scratch off
your list but if you slightly generalize
the problem or just you know consider a
wider class of instances such as the
shortest vector problem on arbitrary
principle ideals this attack doesn't
seem to work at all it the main thing
that makes this attack work is the
promise that there's this exceptionally
short generator in the ideal mean by
exceptionally short I'll say more in a
second yes but let's just call it
exceptionally short for now yeah okay so
as soon as you generalize to say
arbitrary principle ideals in the
shortest vector problem we don't know
how to break that obviously a more
general question beyond that is a
shortest vector in any ideal and this is
the problem that or any ideal in the
ring and this is the problem that we can
reduce to ringing sis and bring all the
beauty and so forth so we seem to the
red seems to be comfortably far away
from the crypto part here at least for
now so yes or equal you should do you
mean to put less at least in one of
those inequalities so well these are
these are reductions right these are
things that can prove as reductions
yeah yeah I mean you want me to prove p
equals P is not different from empty or
so they do it if you want but you see
believe each of them is significantly
more difficult or belief yeah yeah okay
so I mean this is a personal personal
belief but obviously I think that this
is probably a strict inequality here at
least given what we know how to do from
here to here I'm not so sure if its
strict or not there are reasons to think
maybe it's not maybe they're equivalent
it's not i'm not clear from here to here
actually could be strict as well we
don't know you know if I if you gave me
an Oracle for SVP in ideal lattices I
still wouldn't I don't know how to use
that to break ring sis so there could be
strictness here there's probably no
strictness here the first vote should
probably be straight with you don't oh
yeah I think I think probably this one
is strict and this one is a good chance
of being strict yeah
and crypto here just needs some crypto
right yeah I mean any crypto that's
built on these problems right okay so I
already said it but I'll just put it on
the screen now so that the attack the
reason the attack works it's really
crucially relying on the ideal having
this exceptionally short generator and
just to give you a flavor these ideals
are actually extremely rare so if you
look at the set of all principal ideals
in you know fixed ring for most of these
ideals the shortest generator and the
ideal is actually vastly longer than the
shortest vector in the ideal so so
having a short generator is actually
useless to you as the attacker you can
prove this yeah yeah this is you can
formalize it the yeah you can quantify
it it's like at least two to the root n
factor you I can yeah yeah in terms of n
in terms of n it's about two to the root
n factor horse yeah yeah yes this line
sure yeah so all of this is predicated
on fixing a ring and cyclotomic rings
are the most popular and then all of
these reductions hold for any fixed
cyclotomic ring also this race much less
is known much else is now well I mean
all of these will hold forum for
essentially any reasonable ring that you
choose so so this the sequence of
reductions holds for any reason will
ring but I don't even know if if it's
red on the left first of all I deals
where the generating said said this 90
step closer to this non principle ideals
where the generating set is tiny what
does it mean all those generators oh the
so the pair well that actually doesn't
happen I mean the canonical way of
getting two generators is one of them is
the norm of your ideal which will tend
to be enormous maybe there are other
ways of getting too but usually you
never usually you don't present an ideal
in this way and I in a cryptosystem I
get mean you can but most systems don't
so Damian yeah you can loot Lewis
retrace on Jeju it was too short to
image you cannot yeah that's what I was
saying one of them will be the
determinant right you cannot okay at all
good you can okay you can ken okay
Kirksey stall I see okay so in that case
I mean if I if you give me two short
generators yeah
but if you request if you restrict white
yours that have two short generators
restrict missing because it for myself
so maybe that will be open problem 2.5
at the end or so so wait so what's the
difference between that one you have so
when you have only one generator than
asking for that one generator that is
restriction but not in the case where
you have to jannat restriction okay okay
so there is a gap between one versus two
and now it would seem so yeah okay so
maybe the lesson the lesson that I take
at least as a biased observer of course
is that it seems like devising hard
distributions of lattice problems is
really tough especially if you want to
embed some kind of trap door or
information you know that lets you
decrypt or something like that so
Danielle ease talk also had you know the
fall of lattice crypto systems in the
80s where everything people proposed you
end up getting broken because of this
hidden structure so it seems to be very
tough to do but this is where worst case
hardness proofs really kind of show
their show their value they provably
protect you from weak instances from
generating or using week instances so if
you use the distributions given to you
that have worst case hardness you know
you're not going to end up you know
relying on a problem that is much easier
than you thought it was for at least a
much more specialized version of the
problem okay so we should get to some
technical content so i want to show you
just the main idea is the geometric
pictures of the log unit lattice and
then a quick outline of the attack and
how we we prove it but i won't be able
to say too much about how we prove it
okay so we're using this object called
the log unit lattice and in order to
define this we need to talk about
embeddings so we've seen this once or
twice earlier in the week but in case
you don't remember so if you take a
number field k we can write it as the
rationals
with a determinant X modulo some
polynomial f which is irreducible over
the rationals and it has degree n and so
we have what these things called the
complex embeddings so these are the
functions from these are injective
homomorphism from the note from the
number field into the complex numbers
and basically they just send X to each
of the roots of F ok so we have n of
these embeddings one for each root of F
they basically correspond to evaluating
the polynomial at that complex root and
so the canonical embedding Maps you from
k into c to the n where you simply put
all the evaluations we just evaluate all
the embeddings on other value works and
i'll show a picture of this on the next
slide so that's standard stuff more
standard stuff is this thing called the
log embedding a logarithmic embedding
and this Maps you from the number field
minus zero into the reels and
dimensional reels and basically all you
do is take the log of each of these
embeddings each of these coordinates
well you can't take loads of complex
numbers in well you can't get a real
number out of it you take the log of
their magnitudes log of Sigma 1 of X
magnitude 3 log of Sigma X and as you
know when you take logs it converts
multiplication to addition so this is a
group homomorphism from the field minus
0 under multiplication to addition in R
to the N so you can just see that's
because multiplication here becomes
multiplication coordinate wise here and
then when you take magnitudes that's
multiplication and then taking logs
transit in addition I guess this well
not of not of K the image of K minus 0
is not allowed us but for the ring it
will be yeah we'll see it in a second so
just for an example our power of two
cycle tomek the embeddings simply map x2
odd powers of the 2n throught of unity
principle to
so I'll make it to the one to the three
to the five and so forth okay so just to
give us some understanding if I take the
log of any power of X log embedding of
any power of X I just get all of all
zeros vector that's because X to the j
well i replace x with omega which is a
review nity any power of a root of unity
still has magnitude 1 and log of 1 is 0
and so all of these logs are 0 log of 1
minus X is a little more interesting I
was going to write it on the whiteboard
but let's skip it because we have a
better picture anyway so here's a
pictorially web the embedding and the
log in bedding look like for the Rings e
a join square root 2 so this is not a
cyclic ring but cyclotomic Tsar to high
dimensional for for me to put them on
the slide so the x axis is our first
embedding that map's a plus B route 22
itself and then Sigma to the y axis is
its conjugation so it sends a plus B
over 2a minus B route to so if you take
the element 1 it gets mapped to 1 comma
1 that's here if you take the element
route to it gets mapped to root 2
negative root 2 which is down here and
and so forth so in this rings you join
route to you get this nice lattice
structure and multiplication is
component wiser or component wise on the
x and y axis so we have we have
symmetries this lattice of symmetries
multiplication by minus 1 and x 2 root 2
rather and conjugation is another one
but here's what I really want to show
you to get some better intuition so
ignore this line about blue what we have
our units and more generally iso norms
so we can partition the elements of this
ring according to their norm okay and
their norm is just the product of the
the two embeddings so in this case it's
a minus so a squared minus 2b squared
and so all the elements that have norm 1
or minus 1 are on these red hyperbola
which is just
XY equals 14 x y equals minus one over
here and these hyperbolas here you can
see some elements on these red
hyperbolas down there and there and then
elements that have norm two or four you
can see on each of these I so norm
hyperbolas so any questions about this
okay so it's a nice picture let's now
take logs and see what happens so on the
left is just a picture ahead before and
when we take logs of the magnitudes we
get a picture that looks like this ok so
these hyperbolas now become straight
lines they become log X plus log y
equals log of some integer so what we
see here is that the units the blue
points on the red hyperbola is here
become now the blue points on this line
of X plus y equals zero and well look
it's pretty nice right it seems to be a
lattice interesting and then all these
others so in fact it is it's a rank one
lattice so the blue points on the red
line is a rank one lattice of nr2 and
it's orthogonal to this one one vector
here if you look at these other ISO
norms these other lines what you see is
that for any particular line you have a
finite number of shifted copies of the
lattice that's in the red line here ok
sometimes it's one copy sometimes it's
two copies sometimes it's zero copy is
for example there's no element that has
norm three in this ring oh wait is that
three
I can't count I think that's right yeah
yeah norm one two three
yeah so some of these may be empty okay
so that's the picture and now we can
actually make this a bit formal like
Daniel I asked so if we take the group
of Units multiplicative units we call
that our our times or our star and then
we say let lambda be the log-log
embedding of this set of units here and
so dearest way in the 1800's gave his
famous unit theorem which says that our
picture our understanding is what you
think the colonel of the log is actually
just the roots of unity in our so that's
something something not too exciting but
it's like we saw right log of X to the J
was always zero those are the only kinds
of elements you have in the kernel vlog
and more usefully the image under the
log embedding of our star is a lattice
that has rank R plus C minus 1 where r
is the number of real embeddings in to
see we have C pairs of complex
embeddings so good we're going to use
this facts the fact that this really is
a lattice and we can now cast the
problem of finding a short generator as
a CVP type problem or a decoding type
problem so the statement is the
following elements GNH in the ring when
did they generate the same ideal they
generate the same ideal if and only if
they differ multiplicatively by some
unit okay so every element every
multiple of G can be written as a
multiple of H and vice versa so there's
to be a unit ratio between them if we
take logs of this relation here we just
get laud g is log h plus log you log you
obviously lives in this log unit landing
so log she just lives in log h plus
lambda and if we're interested in a
smallest generator so g is a smallest
generator if and only if log g is a
smallest or shortest element in this co
set of vente of the log unit Linus
and I put quotes around these words
because it's a little bit of a liar as
little imprecision there but that's the
the intuition right so if you can find a
short element in this co set you've
found a short generator so that's what
we're going to try to do and I won't
show the algorithm because there's no
algorithm it's just uh well you'll see
oh well we can do it we can do it by
picture okay so this is this is what we
do again this is our picture of the
embedding without logs and this is the
picture with the logs and so I want you
to imagine the following experiment we
pick the generator G ok to be relatively
short or from a Gaussian of some width
and then I don't tell you g but I tell
you some H right which generates the
same ideal so we know that G and H live
on the same I so norm ok so they live on
the same line here right so I tell you H
and maybe H lies way way up here or
something like that about not on that
one well how do you how do you find G or
how do you hope to find G simply you
want to translate H by some points of
the dual of the log unit lattice
translate it to bring it into maybe this
region here ok so this this beam of
light here corresponds to the the flood
light that you see on the left there so
the bottom line is this is a fundamental
domain here this range from here to here
is a fundamental region of the log unit
lettuce so if your original generator
was anywhere in this flood light area
you would recover it ok because i would
give you this H it would be way out here
but she would bring it back you know
into here which would be in this club I
division is that clear that makes me
there is right right yeah so the
question is could there be you know 2
g's for that generate the same ideal
that both live in the floodlight region
it turns out that that won't be the case
for typical distributions yet won't be
the case which is yeah this is sort of
counterintuitive it's a very
counterintuitive but it happens to be
the case so the point is if you can
bring your point out here back into the
fundamental region just by shifting it
by lattice points into this region and
your original generator lived in this
region then you've recovered that
generator and you're done so you don't
have to use I mean this is the best
fundamental region to use but if you use
something else something we shifted over
here it would change the set of
generators that you're able to recover
or not but the most natural one is is to
use the centered centered beam of light
here so that's the algorithm there's
really nothing to it what you have to
show is that it actually works which is
is more interesting so this is only the
one-dimensional case right we have a
one-dimensional log unit lattice here
there's only one meaningful basis of it
in general if you want to solve CVP or
BDD you need to have some kind of good
basis for your lattice that you're using
so the simplest algorithm says okay
given a basis and a target just kind of
take the fractional part of its the
targets coefficients and then return
that to bring it into the fundamental
region of your basis so that's all
that's all this does and what you can
show it's a homework exercise is that if
your original generator or your error
term the log of it satisfies this so the
dot product with the dual of the basis
vectors is between minus a half and half
then you actually recover the generator
just simple homework and so what we have
to show is that that's the case so our
overall analysis or the outline of the
proof is as follows first we want we
need to construct a basis B of the log
unit lattice and this is not entirely
trivial in fact it's an open problem how
to do this but there's an almost basis
okay there's a basis if you crack open
your textbook there are these special
sets of units in the cyclic ring which
almost are almost a basis they generate
a very very dense sub lattice of the
full log unit lattice and it's an open
question for at least a hundred years to
actually compute and find the full group
of units so in terms of conjectures it's
conjectured that these guys generate
almost all the units in terms of
conjectures the hierarchy that the
afghani told us this morning you know he
made up a conjecture that he's willing
to believe this is a conjecture made up
a hundred years ago i'm willing to
believe it okay so that's one little
technical piece now once we have this
basis or almost basis we just have to
show that it's good that that is that
all its dual vectors are relatively
short and it turns out this basis is
really really good it's like vastly
better than we would even need to do
things and then we just have to show
that if you choose a generator according
to a Gaussian or relatively short that
it satisfies this condition so that it
does you do decode and get that
generator out disciples there you see
the basis so you know the conjecture
well in a power of two cycle tomek ring
there's a conjecture due to vapor that
this does generate the all the units in
non power of two cycle tommix that is
known to be false but it generates the
sub lattice of very small index like
five or three and really tiny and that's
enough for us yes sure even doesn't
generate isn't that enough it was so
DVD as long as I'm no it's not enough
because the H that we get is shifted by
an arbitrary unit so it's it's not a
it's not what you think that way yeah
okay so we have to do one has been done
for us we have to do two and three to do
number two you break open your textbook
by Serge Lang or Washington and you find
the proof that the regular find the
proof that these generate a finite index
sub lattice of the units and then you
look in the proof and you realize that
there are tools in there that let you
actually understand the geometry of
these basis vectors so and things bave
really well these vectors these dual
vectors are roughly 1 over root m where
m is the index or the dimension of the
of the ring and that's way way better
than then you need and then and then
this is similar when you talk about
you're talking about logs of gaussians
and you need to see how they project
onto these factors here okay so a little
over time I'll finish with three open
problems in order of difficulty easy
would be to say let's extend this to
non-prime power cycle to mix these these
are this formula doesn't work to give
you units like you want when it's not a
prime power there are other formulas you
could see how the geometry looks for
those those formulas it's probably a
worthwhile but not terribly difficult
exercise I think it shouldn't be too
hard to say well how far can we extend
this can we do this for non cyclotomic
families of number fields it would be
enough to just find like be able to
write down or analyze or computationally
find a good enough basis of the log unit
lattice or or some dense sub lattice of
it so if you can do that for some nice
family you would have you'd have a
solution and then a hard is actually
give a bound on that that finite index
that we know so open for a hundred years
but why not now right so here's a good
reason may be a good reason to actually
solve this famous
favorite class number problem right
that's all thanks